شمس الشتاء على شاطئ كوف في دبي
لأولئك الذين يعانون من عمليات
الإغلاق الشديدة في أوروبا وخارج
أماكن مثل هذه تثير مزيجًا من
الحسد
والغضب للسائحة الدنماركية إيما ماتيلد ، فإن
رد الفعل العنيف
ليس مفاجئًا للغاية حيث يذهب الجميع إلى
هنا ويكون الجو
مشمسًا ويمكنهم الذهاب  في الخارج لتناول الطعام ثم
يبدأون في النشر على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ، ولهذا السبب يغضب الناس
من سبب اضطرارنا للبقاء في المنزل عندما
يستمتع الآخرون بحياتهم على
الشاطئ وقائمة المشاهير التي تم ضخها
من قبل المؤثرين على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
أعطت الانطباع  أن دبي
فتحت أبوابها للعالم الخارجي
ليس من المستغرب أن أولئك الذين يبحثون عن
مناخ أكثر دفئًا وبعض المرح في الشمس انضموا إلى
الفنادق التي عانت لمدة عام تقريبًا
وشهدت الحجوزات ارتفاعاً هائلاً
ولكن أيضًا تطمع 19 حالة
تضاعفت أربع مرات فوق المستويات التي رأيناها
في نوفمبر الماضي جميعًا  حدث رائع أن هذه الزيادة
حدثت على الرغم من أن المؤسس المشارك لشركة كوف
بيتش قال
إن عدد الزوار لمكانه
كان ثلث ما كان عليه
سابقًا  emic
بما يتماشى مع الإمارة بشكل عام عندما
يتم إغلاق أوروبا لسوء الحظ في
الولايات المتحدة يتم إغلاقها في
آسيا ، أي شيء تفعله يمكن أن ينظر إليه
بعيدًا عن الخط ، الاستجابة في
الصحافة البريطانية حيث تم وضع الإمارات العربية المتحدة
على
القائمة الحمراء لحظر السفر  كلمة
رئيسية شرسة تلقي باللوم على
الزائرين لكونها متعجرفة
للغاية ، والإمارة بسبب ذهابها بعيدًا عن
دبي المعروفة
بدفعها للأمام من خلال عرضها الجذاب
للترفيه والهندسة المعمارية ،
تكثف استجابتها بناءً على
البيانات التي تجمعها
وليس الغضب العالمي  حلال العمري هو
المدير العام
لهيئة السياحة في دبي ، فنحن ننظر
إلى هذا القطاع بعناية فائقة حسب القطاع
والقطاع الفرعي لنرى أين نحتاج
إلى تشديد القيود وأين نحتاج إلى
رفع القيود ،
وسيستمر ذلك لا علاقة له بما
يخبرنا أي شخص آخر لأن هناك
خطة واضحة جدًا
اعتبارًا من نوادي الشاطئ يوم الثلاثاء ،
ستقتصر سعة الفنادق ومراكز التسوق على 70 في المائة
وستقتصر دور السينما على  تم إغلاق 50 في المائة من الحانات
والحانات مؤقتًا
مع فرض عقوبات أشد على
منتهكي القواعد ، وتشير الحكومة إلى
أن الإمارات قامت بالفعل بتطعيم
ما يقرب من خُمس سكانها مجانًا من
خلال خطة لتلقيح نصف جميع
السكان
بحلول نهاية المسيرة.  بهذه الوتيرة ، لم يتم النظر في
فكرة العودة إلى الإغلاق
الكامل قبل 10 أشهر ،
فهل هناك
موافقة كاملة داخل الحكومة
حتى هيئة الصحة التي تتعرض لضغوط
بحيث يمكنك اتباع هذه المنهجية في
جميع القرارات
المتعلقة بالجمهور  تقود
هيئة صحية وعالم يجلس
هناك
كل ما يوصون به ، فنحن نعمل مع
القطاع الخاص للتأكد من أنه يتم
تنفيذه بأفضل طريقة ممكنة
، فالواقع الاقتصادي هو وجود بئر نفط
في أبو ظبي المجاورة
ومعرض عالمي لاستضافة  في وقت لاحق من هذا العام ،
تحتاج دبي إلى الحفاظ على التجارة والخدمات السياحية
تتداول هذه النظرة من قبل
أصحاب الأعمال وغيرهم
ممن يسمون دبي هوم  أعتقد أنهم
أرسلوا بالفعل رسالة إلى العالم
مفادها أنه
إذا خرجت الأمور عن السيطرة ، فنحن
نعلم أننا لسنا خجولين للإغلاق
والتعديل على الفور ولا ننتظر
الآن ، تحتاج الحكومة إلى إقناع
بقية العالم بأنها تمتلك  التوازن الصحيح
بين الأمان والانفتاح
مع بقاء بضعة أشهر في ذروة
موسم السفر